in the United States no one has
successfully challenged an incumbent
president for his own party's nomination
in more than a century and a half and
President Trump with his approval rating
among Republicans at 80 to 90% has
laughed off any suggestion his
nomination is in jeopardy but on Sunday
former congressman joe walsh became the
second Republican to announce a longshot
bid to unseat Trump in the primaries I'm
running because he's unfit somebody
needs to step up and there needs to be
an alternative the country is sick of
this guy's tantrum he's he's a child
intra-party challenges to a sitting
president are rare but have happened
before Ronald Reagan strongly challenged
President Gerald Ford in 1976 Ted
Kennedy came close to winning the
nomination against Jimmy Carter in 1980
and Pat Buchanan challenged the first
President Bush in 1992 each incumbent
went on to lose the general election
[Music]
Walsh and fellow Republican presidential
challenger William weld a former
governor are both considered longshots
against Trump to call it suicide would
be pretty close to accurate at this
point but a lot can happen in six months
especially with potential economic
downturn loon looming we know that the
president's approval rating is very
closely tied to the health of the
economy and any continued problems with
trade and such could really dent the
president Trump has weathered a rough
week escalating the us-china trade war
labeling the chair of the US Federal
Reserve and enemy and ordering private
businesses to not do business with China
but the Republican National Committee is
right behind the president and he's
raised a small fortune for his campaign
which make it difficult for anyone to
challenge him and win going forward much
rests on how the US economy will perform
in the next few months this week ended
with stock prices
lay over uncertainty about Trump's
handling of the us-china trade war but
overall gains in the economy and job
growth have been robust under Trump's
presidency also members of his party
have rallied behind the president for
his pics of conservatives to the US
Supreme Court all of which is to say
that Trump still enjoys immense support
among his Republican base and any
challenge coming from within his own
party to become the next presidential
nominee is very unlikely to succeed